first off show of hands who's got fake
titties
I bet you're too you're like gonna get
blocked today
boom boom three just three only three
okay
mine are real uh was it worth it
um within the first week uh I would say
the benefits that it came with the
attention and everything I was in a
relationship at the time when I got them
but after we broke up yeah the attention
was nice it was cool I didn't really you
know I kind of I could kind of tell that
men were after me you know because you
know I have like a big Double D and
stuff but physically I don't think
they're worth it because I used to get
like pleasure from my aerialism and I
can't feel a [__] thing and they hurt
half the time how long ago did you get
news done because it can come 20 20. I
only have a feeling in one of mine yeah
they've gotten me indoors I I can't
complain